if you can 100% commit to this challenge
in the next 90 days you will drastically
transform your trading if you can't
stick to this 90-day challenge you
probably don't have what it takes to be
successful at trading if I discovered
this earlier on in my trading I would
have started making consistent money 5
years earlier than I did this challenge
will help you escape that cycle of
consistently losing money and turn your
trading into a money printing machine to
make money trading you have to focus on
the process of getting 1% better every
day you won't tangibly notice yourself
getting better daily or even weekly but
over months you can look back and you
will see a drastic difference once I
realized trading Psychology was the key
to be successful at trading I went from
consistently losing to starting to
consistently make money that's why over
this challenge not only do you need a
track on how and why you got into your
trades based on your strategy but what
emotions were you feeling when you made
the trading decision did you get into a
trade too early because you had the fear
of missing out or did you jump out of a
trade too early because you felt the
fear of the trade turning against you
and you didn't want to give up your
profit now if you don't have a trading
strategy I will show you a trading
strategy that I use that you can use
during this Challenge in a minute you
have to remember trading is
statistically based just because a trade
lost does not mean you did something
wrong or your strategy didn't work I got
the privilege of talking to a hedge fund
manager about back testing or reviewing
your trades and he said the biggest
issue people have is unknowingly making
changes that hurt their overall
profitability what he means by that is
thinking that every trading loss you
take has something fixable would either
make it profitable or avoid the loss
entirely the market has infinite
possibilities anything can happen every
loss doesn't have a lesson sometimes
that lesson is just that things don't
always go in your favor you can take a
good trade setup and still turn into a
loss he also stated that back testing is
almost worthless when it comes to a
specific Trader's profitability because
at the end of the day a Trader success
is based off of their psychology and
ability to execute the strategy the
biggest reason people fail at trading is
because when the strategy doesn't work
out they look for other things and
patterns to make it work or they
switched a whole new strategy and I like
to call this the infinite learning Loop
there are infinite ways to trade in the
markets and there is always interest new
information out there that you can find
this is where the 90day challenge comes
into play so the first thing that you
need to do to stick to this challenge is
to open up a separate trading account or
if you're just starting out open up two
demo accounts you're going to have one
account that you focus your main
strategy on and this Challenge on and if
you don't have a strategy again I'm
about to show you one you can use every
day then the second account is so you
can try other patterns or strategies
that you feel the urge to test when it
comes to journaling track them
separately the whole idea of this
challenge is to make you stick to one
strategy and prove to yourself that it
works remember the biggest reason people
fail in trading is that learning Loop
that they get stuck in it seems so basic
and dumb but to be successful at trading
you have to do what people aren't
willing to do and as basic as it sounds
people aren't willing to push through
the struggle of sticking to one strategy
and working on perfecting that they
constantly want to look for the next
pattern or indicator that will make
things easily work without putting the
hard effort into trading so for the next
90 days trade one strategy in your main
account stick through it through thick
or thin even if it seems like it's not
working out because you need to build a
journal of Trades so you can see what's
working and what's not don't make
changes to your strategy right away you
need to stick to at least 20 to 30
trades to get enough data to logically
be able to make a change to your
strategy if you want to make a change
after a couple of losses
that's your emotions wanting to make a
change because of fear of losing money
if you feel the urge to try other
patterns that's what the separate
account is for you can still make money
from them but it keeps the accounts
separate and the strategy separate so
when the dust settles you can tangibly
see the results to get the most out of
this challenge create a framework that
you can focus on every day focus on
building habits to keep you on the right
track one thing I do is I read my
trading plan and my goals right before I
trade so I'm focused on sticking to the
strategy and not the results of making
money I look at previous trade setups
that I liked so I know what good ones
look like I remind myself what I'm
looking out for when I'm trading trading
psychology is the key to become
successful at trading but having a
strategy that you can be confident in is
a foundation of everything especially
when back testing doesn't really work
let me walk you through the strategy
that I've honed and traded over the
years of my trading that you'll be able
to use with confidence Ence during this
challenge so the strategy I use is
really really simple it can be used on
any Market or any time frame but what I
do is I focus on reversal trades on the
Futures market and so another thing that
made me profitable was realizing that
one strategy and one pattern makes it
easy and simple to focus on to become
profitable and so what that pattern is
for me is looking for reversals in the
market the market has ranges that it
constantly makes between resistance and
support levels and it will just pingpong
back between those levels and so what I
have realized over time is that easy you
can find those levels pretty easily and
then you can bet that the Market's going
to go down off of those levels and keep
your risk relatively low and then your
potential profit much higher which for
trading is really good you want a
favorable risk reward and other than
that I just stay out of the market
because again it keeps things simple and
you can focus on essentially the low
hang hanging fruit and so this strategy
can be used on really any Market or any
time frame if you want to trade Forex
crypto Futures whatever you want you can
do on a hour 4H hour chart daily chart
but what I do is I focus trading on the
Futures markets they allow you to day
trade with a small account and I trade
on a 15minute and a 1 minute chart so I
trade a little quicker but you can still
use these Concepts on a lot larger time
frame if you like it now so the first
thing that I do is I have two separate
time frames that I look at and so how
that works is on the 15minute time frame
what we're currently looking at is
that's where I look for those swings in
the market to draw the resistance or
support levels and so all I pretty much
do for those is I look for two kind of
clear touches in the market or some kind
of signal to show that okay there's a
resistance level up here and then
essentially you just wait for the market
to come up to those levels right here
did a smaller reversal off that level
it's come up here again and then you
know you can kind of bet that the
Market's going to go down off of it and
currently the Market's kind of sold off
from that level there and so what I
would then do is go into a one minute
chart look for a couple signals and kind
of a five-step framework checklist that
I've created to simplify the entries
into these patterns so to show you what
a real example of this looks like let me
walk you through a trade that I recently
took using this exact strategy and I'll
show you the five step checklist
framework that I use pretty much every
trade I get into and again the first
thing is looking for either that
resistance or support level off of that
larger time frame we kind of just walk
through that and again that's usually
just looking for you know a couple
swings and then when the market comes up
again like we are right here looking for
a couple key things to jump in betting
that the Market's going to go down and
so this trading strategy you can bet
that the Market's going to go up off of
a support level or like we are now you
can bet that it's going to go down and I
actually have more success betting that
the Market's going to go down I don't
know why but over time I've Just Seen
myself more successful with that and
then the next thing is making sure that
uptrend is actually broken in so you can
expect that the market is going to
reverse you know you often hear that the
trend is your friend and so if the trend
is still showing that it's going to come
continue higher well you don't want to
bet that the Market's going to go down
cuz then you're attempting to go counter
Trend the whole idea is to try and
predict and have reasons to say that
well I think the trend is ending here
you can see it start to kind of fizzle
out here and then you can bet the
Market's going to go lower and so an
easy way I do that is just drawing a
trend line and then also looking at the
swings in the market the market pretty
much just makes higher highs H in an
uptrend and then when it switches it
starts to make lower highs and so here
it starts making lower highs and the
lows start getting lower as well and so
that's kind of that Trend shifting
confirmation that I really like to look
for and then the fourth thing is looking
for that market to essentially make one
of those lower highs here and it
actually does it right here before the
trend is broken and so if you ever see
that this can sometimes happen is I wait
until it essentially breaks that Trend
and then you can see here it made
another lower high and that's plenty
good confirmation to still get in on and
then the final thing is you want to see
a strong reversal Candlestick really
confirming one of those lower highs
because you don't want to get in like
right here if you look this is kind of a
weak bearish Candlestick it's a dogee
it's just there's a lot of chop going on
right here it doesn't really show you
strength and conviction that the Market
could continue lower now it totally can
off of that but it's not a really good
confirmation versus right here you can
see the market essentially if you look
at these two candlesticks the market
basically did a big move up kind of
pulled back a little bit and then it
goes to the next Candlestick that's
pretty much in the one Candlestick and
then in the next Candlestick it opens up
here can tries to go higher again it
goes a little bit higher and then
reverses lower a lot and so that's a
strong move of essentially the market
making a Mini double top and reverse Al
and so that's where I jump in I jump in
right kind of at the break of that
candle and then bet the Market's going
to go lower and I just put my stop kind
of above here as you know a good spot
based on just the market making these
lower highs because you know if it's
going to keep going higher you're wrong
that's totally okay but like we talked
about in the beginning your risk reward
ratio is really favorable because you're
risking about this and if I try and you
know make that about the same size you
can see I'm already about up 2x down
here is three you could go to four cuz
again you're you're catching those
potential swings in the market and swing
if we look over here just looking to the
left of the chart there's kind of a
double bottom here kind of a larger Head
and Shoulders that's probably where the
market might bounce right and so that's
a lot of good R to profit and so that's
kind of a hidden checklist item that you
really want to look out for as well is
there actually room for my trade to make
me good money essentially is there good
risk reward potential because if there's
a support level right here well yeah you
can kind of get a little bit of a trade
here but is it really worth the risk of
you know the initial risk that you put
on jumping on into the trade you want to
make sure these things line up really
well because I I only take a couple of
these every week that's what trading is
all about is waiting patiently for
things to line up perfectly because then
you can jump in on a trade and you can
get really good risk reward and
potential consistent profits from doing
it the hard part is patiently waiting
for your one strategy to hold up and
that's what this challenge is all about
and so just to quickly talk about this
strategy is how I manage it is well I
move to break even kind of when it
started going in my favor and then you
can see now here is we're in a tight
downtrend and so my thought is well
we're kind of getting near the lows and
the Market's gone really well in my
favor for me once I get up to about
three times my risk I like to Trail up
my stop and jump out when it breaks the
previous Candlestick high so that's kind
of what it does here and it's a really
nice profit every Trader out there loses
thousands of dollarss making these
mistakes if you can avoid each one of
these mistakes you will be light years
ahead of every Trader out there these
are mistakes I constantly see failing
Traders making and I myself have had to
overcome these mistakes to become a
consistently profitable Trader so the
first thing most people figure out is
when you come to trading you have to
have a trading plan now the biggest
mistake though that I make sometimes and
I see a lot of people doing is not
actually following that plan is you
follow it most to the time but there's
times when you slip up following it you
have to stick to your plane rigorously
that is the thing that is going to keep
you profitable and consistent as a
Trader is because you spent all this
time building a profitable plan or a
plan that theoretically should be
profitable and you have to give it time
to actually work out and for me right
here to show you an example of this
mistake I was making I had number two of
my checklist work lineup and I had
number three of my checklists but there
was no real support level down here that
I was looking for I really was just
seeing hey the market kind of came in
this downtrend and it's kind of chopping
here and so you know I fom moded in
wanting to jump on this level of
thinking oh well you know maybe I don't
have a support level here that I've
drawn from before but maybe it'll still
work out because I have two and three of
my checklist but I don't have one and
you have to have all of your plan lineup
to Signal a trade otherwise you're just
randomly trading and you you cannot be
doing that because that's not repeatable
and you have to have something that you
can consistently repeat in the markets
to be consistently profitable and of
course when you do something like this
it's always going to turn out to be a
loss maybe you'll get a lucky a couple
times which is really bad because it'll
reinforce you taking a bad trade because
well you won so maybe it wasn't a bad
trade but in reality you have to stick
to your rules or you're going to end up
losing a lot of money and waste a lot of
time so to walk through another big
mistake an example is well this one I'm
following my plan I have a support level
the downtrend is broken there's even a
little one right here that's broken and
then there's a nice Candlestick entry
pattern but the biggest mistake I see
people make and I'm making here is if
you look at the market see how the
market is acting if you look at all
these candlesticks they are very very
stacked on top of each other there's a
lot of back and forth and choppiness in
the market and so because because of
that you have to realize that if the
Market's going to make a big swing like
this in One Direction it's going to be
very very hard to capture that movement
because even if the market does go in
your favor it's going to have a lot of
back and forth and when you're at kind
of the lows like I am right here trying
to catch a reversal to the highs and
because the Market's choppy it's more
likely that you get false signals
because the Market's just going back and
forth and chopping around and because of
that it's also likely that you get
trapped or the market just doesn't work
out because it's more likely to just
kind of stagnate and sit there versus
giving a nice swing in your direction
and because of that as well it's hard to
capture a big clean move in the market
because it's likely that even here you
can see there was a massive sell-off
here but because the Market's choppy
it's likely to just reverse that back up
and continue to sit there so even if a
move happens it's unlikely that you can
easily capture that move now one of the
hardest things to grasing trading is
when you take a perfect looking Trade It
lines up with all your rules and it just
doesn't work out right here this trade
is awesome there is a resistance level
up here a the uptrend is broken and
there is a really sick reversal
Candlestick right here and so I think
for me for my strategy I think this
looks amazing for the market to break
going lower because we've had a nice
Trend break it's kind of lost some steam
it made one more attempt to keep going
higher and then there's massive
rejection right here from Sellers and so
I think it's very likely that we keep
going lower and I would take this trade
every single time but sometimes the
market gives you a signal it looks
really good and it still doesn't work
out and that is totally part of trading
you have to accept that you are going to
have losses even on the best looking
trades and so that's why you have to
have really good risk management when it
comes to trading as well you want every
trade to be the same size because if I
saw this trade right here that looks
amazing and I thought this is 100%
guaranteed to work out the moment we
start thinking that run away and if I
bet you know my whole account on it well
there's a chance that it doesn't work
out and this trade does end up being a
loser even though it looks so good and I
would take this trade every single time
but again that's a part of trading and
if you didn't have good risk management
and sizing you would end up losing your
whole account and that is another
mistake people make is they go too big a
size on certain trades you want to have
good risk management with your trading
because not all trades are going to win
that's a part of trading again we're in
it for the long haul the numbers game
you want to be consistently profitable
over 100 trades and of course some of
those are going to be losers and that is
totally okay because again that is just
a part of the game trading now this
mistake right here plagued me for years
and this is why I have my checklist of
entering we have good resistance level
up here the uptrend is broken and
there's kind of a good signal here but
it's jumping the gun on a trade when you
see the potential coming right when you
are trading you want to have a plan of
what you're looking for and when you see
that plan starting to align up of one
resistance level and two the uptrend is
broken looking for a reversal well you
start to get antsy and say okay all we
need is one more thing just need the
final confirmation we want a a good
bearish Candlestick and you can jump
dump the gun when not everything is
quite aligned and it can cause a lot of
consistent losses because you're just
getting in too aggressively in the
market and it can be really really
frustrating doing that versus waiting
for that actual strong confirmation that
you're plan asks for for my plan right
here this Candlestick didn't really show
enough of rejection of that level
because it didn't even give back this
green bullish bar right in reality it
was just a little pullback in this
uptrend we had but here this candlestick
we had some consolidation with these two
candlesticks and then a massive
rejection Candlestick and that's when I
got in on a short betting that the
market was going to go lower and that's
what you need to be looking out for when
your trading is anticipating that a
trade is coming and sitting on your
hands and knees until everything aligns
up properly because I have made so many
mistakes where I see a potential trade
coming I'm theoretically correct because
I in hindsight I see the market go down
but I jump in too early and it can be
extremely frustrating because I'll jump
in take a loss be upset with myself and
maybe just be done for the day and if I
waited just another literally five more
minutes the actual trade would have set
up and so that is something that is
extremely hard to do for me over the
time of trading is just wait another 5
minutes for that final confirmation
because generally those are the best
cleanest and easiest trades to end up
taking is the ones that look insanely
strong not the ones that look pretty
good and they might work out if it's
going through your head that hey this
looks pretty good it might work out it's
not a good enough setup to be taking you
want to be taking those trades that you
see that line up perfectly and you're
like wow this trade looks amazing I have
to get in this right now because it fits
my strategy perfectly and I patiently
waited for it to set up like this so
here's another trade I'm in and this one
actually ends up becoming a winner but I
lose out on hundreds of dollars because
of a big mistake I'm making here and
it's one that I think a lot of people
potentially do when they are trading and
it's getting too greedy when it comes to
your trades when you see them work out
you have to take your profits when the
Market's telling you to when the market
was up this High I was up through four
times my risk I was up5 or $600 and
that's a great amount to make on a trade
you cannot get greedy trying to say okay
well you know maybe the market will pull
back here and then go all the way up
just take the easy money and get out
you're going to lose a lot of money
trying to give the market a lot of
wiggle room in your trades hoping that
it maybe does some crazy move that you
can catch and you can get a home run
just go for the quick easy wins and make
a lot of money that way because again
consistently making three or four times
a risk is going to make you insanely
profitable in the long run another
mistake that I made was looking at stock
chart patterns and thinking that oh I
could just learn these and the market
will fit them and I'll be able to know
what the Market's doing and the market
really never fits these patterns in real
time it can be easy to spot them in
hindsight sometimes but when you're
actually reading the market it can be
pretty hard to spot these and quite
often even if you see them they don't
necessarily play out that way and so
what I found is the most important thing
is just learn to read the candlesticks
of a chart and understand Trends and the
nuts and bolts of just what those are
telling you and you will be able to know
way more about what the market is doing
than just trying to match pictures of
potential chart patterns onto your chart
what took me from making $200 a trade to
making $22,000 a trade wasn't my
strategy it was something that most
Traders aren't even aware of I'm going
to lay out everything that I have
learned in the journey from becoming a
profitable Trader than scaling up my
size by the time you get to the end of
this video you will know what you need
to focus on to succeed in trading and
the steps that you need to take to reach
your goals now there is something in
trading that is completely
counterintuitive and causes failures and
frustrations all the time in traders in
society we learn if you work harder at
something you will become better and
better working 12 hours a day and
something like 7 days a week you will
become a master in no time you will get
ahead of others and become successful
but when it comes to trading it doesn't
exactly work like this initially when
you first start studying for days on end
and looking at charts will get you ahead
head in the learning curve faster but it
hits a point where slaming more hours
into T it just doesn't work I used to
solely focus on trading it was the
biggest focus in my life and I wanted to
become successful as fast as I could so
I traded every day for as many hours as
I could and studied the rest of the
other hours that I was free now what
this does is it puts so much pressure on
your trading I would go into every
trading day with expectations that I was
putting so much effort into it that I
should start seeing results quickly but
after I got through the initial learning
curve and I was focused on executing my
strategy it put pressure on every trade
to succeed every trade had to win and if
it didn't it was just another result
showing that I was failing and not able
to succeed that all the hard work wasn't
getting me anywhere and even if I traded
for just a few hours in the morning if
my trading went good I would be happy
for the rest of the day and if it went
bad and I lost money I would be in a bad
mood the rest of the day because the way
my focus was was that all that mattered
in the day was my trading and so to fix
this instead of trading being the main
key focus in my life I changed it to
just being one of them what changed
things for me was creating other things
to focus on taking the pressure off of
trading from talking to other aspiring
Traders pressure is a massive influence
on their results one of the the biggest
pressures is money most people get into
trading for the income that it can
generate but I've learned through
teaching the more desperate you are for
money sooner it adds more and more
pressure to your trading trading is a
long game and your results can be
measured only over a year span a
consistently profitable Trader can have
losing weeks or losing months but over
the year they are successful this is why
if you have pressure to make money
quickly from Trading or even have a
timeline of when you want to make money
trading it'll put that much pressure on
your results to be positive and will in
turn force you to make impulsive trades
in spots you shouldn't even be in think
of it like this probably the most
impactful trait you have in your trading
is patience if you were a millionaire
and didn't need the money at all and the
sole goal of trading was to consistently
get in a trade when you felt in tune
with the market and the strategy set up
perfectly you could wait until that
exact situation showed up which could be
days weeks or even months depending on
the person then on the flip side if you
need money tomorrow you would likely be
trying to get into a trade no matter how
you felt or how the market looked right
now instead of waiting for the market to
fit your plan you would be trying to
react to the what the market is doing
and fit around it now most of us are
somewhere in the middle of this spectrum
but sit down and spend some time really
thinking about where you are on this
spectrum because the farther in the
direction of I don't need the money
Spectrum the less pressure your trading
will have on it and the farther in the I
need the money right now the more
pressure trading is going to have now I
don't think anyone would trade if there
wasn't money involved so don't think
that you can't get rid of that instead
the thing to focus on is how important
it is for you because if there is a lot
of pressure on you you need to find ways
to try and alleviate some of that
pressure either do something that helps
create money sooner to fill that need
right now and have trading be something
that can in the future become fruitful
or work on rewiring your brain that you
are working on something that will
become successful in the long run it
could take years down the road but once
you get there the effort will be worth
it take that time expectation off of
your trading trading can size up
insanely quickly you could be making
$200 a week from one trade trade but
then a year later you're making $2,000 a
week one trade because you've now sized
up 10x from that one trade this is where
I was a year and a half ago I was making
about $200 a trade and I was focusing on
the process and everything else about my
trading and then as I've got better over
time I've realized okay now I can start
to size up and this can become something
that is actually very very powerful
where trading becomes exponential is the
amount of money you can make from each
trade not from the number of Trades you
take even if you took one trade in the
whole year but made a $100,000 from that
trade that's all you would need here's
an analogy that blew my mind when I
first heard it in trading in poker the
best two starting hands are two Aces two
kings or two queens if you were able to
bet all your money and have someone
match your bet every time you had these
hands you would consistent ly make money
and in the long run make millions now
this doesn't work in poker because
you're playing at a table with people
most people will catch on to what you're
doing because they're watching what
you're doing but in trading no one is at
the other side of the table keeping
track of what you're doing in trading it
doesn't cost as much money to watch the
market compared to in poker you have to
pay the blinds or the anties to play and
in trading you can sit and wait for your
two Aces every time and only put your
money
and risk when you get them the only
hardest part about this is the waiting
game in poker you have about a
0.45% chance of being dealt two aces in
your hand so the odds are really tiny so
you have to see a lot of hands to even
be delt hit and that can take hours on
end but remember every time this happens
you make money in the long run and so
the logical answer is to wait for that
but like with poker and trading sitting
there is really really hard to do and if
you can learn to wait it will pay off
one thing that's really helped me is I
used to trade for hours and hours on end
and that patience would be really really
hard to do and recently what has really
changed this for me is focusing on only
trading for an hour to 2 hours a day
because that's when I can focus on being
patient and then just move on with the
day because just looking at the charts
and doing just that is really boring
especially when there's nothing going on
or you see the potential for a trade to
go on and so I can only be patient for a
short amount of period of time and so
that's what I've done with my trading
I've allowed myself to only trade a
short period of time so then I can be
patient and then I just move on to the
next day when I've taken trades or that
time runs out if you go into every
trading day focusing on that of
practicing patience
it will drastically change your trading
because this is what the majority of
people can't do which is keeping them
from being profitable if you can Master
patience you can make money trading you
want to go into every trading day
focusing on your plan for the market if
the market doesn't fit that you don't
take a trade a massive mindset mistake
beginning Traders have is a goal for a
certain amount of money or trades in a
given day I struggled for the longest
time with the idea of having a trading
goal with either the amount of Trades I
wanted to take or the amount of money I
wanted to make but these all put
pressure on my trading if you have a set
number of Trades you want to take in one
day but the market isn't a good trading
condition for your strategy you're going
to be forcing bad trade setups that day
or if you have a daily dollar amount
you're looking to make you're putting
massive pressure on that day to have
good results even if you have a week or
monthly goal you're putting massive
pressure on your results honestly having
any result oriented goals isn't good for
trading when I started to find some
success at trading I had a goal that
when I hit a certain amount of size I
would increase my trading size sounds
totally fine right but what happened
which I only found out by going through
this process is that as I got closer to
that goal I started to focus on my
results it got in my mind that I only
needed a couple more wins to get to my
goal and I would get to size up which is
exciting in trading sizing up is a sign
of success but this goal had changed my
focus from being focused on the process
to the results again and it started to
damage my trading I realized this and
dropped the goal and instead put a
timeline in place because I felt
confident in my trading that I had been
getting good results that in a couple of
months at the end of the year I would
size up the other big key involved with
this was I mentally felt ready to size
up as well I wasn't nervous about the
size of my trades anymore the risk of
the money didn't scare me anymore it was
more normalized this is a big key to
understand because when you increase
your size it adds more pressure on your
trading and pressure is what we are
trying to focus in on minimizing here
now on the flip side though you don't
want to have zero pressure on your
trading in college I would play poker
with my DMM mates and when we first
started out we didn't put any money on
so if you lost all your chips it didn't
really matter what this did is people
didn't care about what they did they
would go all in betting all their chips
on really bad hands because it was funny
they weren't taking this seriously and I
wanted to take this seriously and so I
got tired of that and I got us all to
put up $20 at stake for the game
immediately the stakes were all high for
us and nobody was randomly going all in
we were all focused on doing the best we
could to win this is the same thing with
trading you need a certain amount of
pressure to take it seriously there
needs to be a reason to take only trades
you want to take not just randomly
petting for fun when you first start
trading it's important to practice on a
demo account because everything is so
new and you're getting used to a
strategy and that takes time it would be
dumb to go right into trading real money
because statistically everyone loses
money when they first start out but once
you get a solid grasp of things you need
to up the stakes because otherwise you
will end up was wasting your time being
like my doormates randomly all Inning on
your demo account because you're bored
you will start actually building bad
trading habits that will later down the
road take months to rebuild by now I'm
sure you can see that to succeed at
trading it isn't about solely learning a
strategy learning to read charts and
patterns is really fairly easy most of
us can recognize patterns humans are
good at that the biggest thing with your
strategy though is try to keep it simple
so you can
get it down and focus on what actually
holds most Traders back from being
successful I've taught a ton of Traders
my strategy and what holds them back is
always the mental side of their trading
you have to work on what most people
aren't willing to do most Traders are
just looking for that easy quick fix of
a strategy or indicator that tells them
what to do or that works all the time
and tells them when to buy and sell but
these don't work and that's why most
people fail at Trading my goal is to
break you free from that losing cycle
into the profitable percentage of
winning Traders now because in trading
everything is really emotional think
about a lot of reasons why you make
emotional decisions in your trading as
humans we are actually programmed to
avoid pain and go to things that feel
good this is why fear and avoiding pain
is generally the emotion that controls
most Traders the fear of missing out is
to avoid the pain of money you could
have made taking profits too early is to
avoid the pain of giving back money you
made not closing out of a losing trade
is to avoid the pain of being wrong or
not entering into a trade is to avoid
the pain of being wrong these emotions
seem really simple but when you really
reflect on them they can be complex and
interconnected for an example my biggest
emotional barrier was I didn't even
enter into a trade because I wanted to
avoid the pain of being wrong I would
spot a trade and get nervous that I
would be wrong and lose so i' then skip
the trade and I'd watch as the market
profited without me I'd feel like a
complete idiot because I had just
chickened out on getting into the trade
I spotted it I knew where to enter I
just couldn't pull the trigger I
continue to trade and the frustration of
that loss would Loom over me I'd spot
another potential opportunity but it
wasn't really good enough for a trade
but out of frustration I would jump into
the trade not wanting to skip out on
another win strategically these trades
are completely separate but emotionally
they were connected if I was able to
accept that I was nervous and just get
into the first trade where I actually
really liked the setup I would have
actually won and probably never got into
the losing trade because I wouldn't have
felt that emotional frustration I was
able to change this over time by
realizing that it's okay to feel nervous
to get into a trade you can just accept
that the nervousness is part of trading
and it's okay to feel that emotion the
big key is to not let those emotions
control your actions that's the biggest
thing that most Traders struggle with is
their emotions are controlling their
actions you can't be an emotionless
robot and just not feel any emotions
that's just not how we're wired but what
you can do is accept an emotion feel it
accept it and then just decide to do
something else just because you're
scared doesn't mean you have to run the
other direction for you to succeed at
trading once you have your strategy
nailed down you need to realize what
emotions are coming up when you're
trading why they happen and what you can
do to either accept them or reframe
things to take them away this is
something that can take an unknown
amount of time depending on the emotion
because these can be so ingrained into
your subconscious they are habits and
patterns that your brain has learned
over time and your goal now is to work
to re wire them when I first started
trading I struggled to find consistent
success I would have success at times
but I wouldn't be able to consistently
keep the profits I made and it just felt
like I was gambling in a casino it took
me four long years to realize that I
would consistently be in this losing
cycle until I made certain changes that
I'm going to reveal to you in this video
once I started to make these changes I
saw my profit graph go from consistently
losing money to consistently making
money every Trader that eventually
becomes profitable has a similar story
to this yours might be slightly
different but if you listen closely to
what I'm about to tell you you will be
able to take actionable steps that will
improve your trading no matter where you
are in the trading Journey consistently
I would find myself in situations where
I'd spot a great potential trade and I'd
end up getting scared that the trade
might end up being a loser I would then
skip the trade and watch as the market
would just Soar Off in the direction of
that trade without me and so instead of
making a few thousand would end up
making zero and I'd always feel like a
complete idiot I then continue to watch
what the market was doing and along
comes another potential trade but this
time it's not as good of a trade
opportunity and I know I should just
skip it but maybe I'm just being scared
and I should just toughen up and get in
I don't want to make the same mistake
twice so I jump into the trade and this
time it fails and I lose money if youve
been in this exact same spot you know
how frustrating this is because of that
loss now you start doubting yourself you
start beating yourself up and I would
get even more triggered i' either leave
trading for the day quit it and I would
have you know a dark cloud over me the
rest of the day it would kind of ruin my
day or even worse I would actually end
up stay trading and start Revenge
trading and take even more losses even
if you're dealing with this with your
trading right now I have answers for you
let's talk about a few key takeaways
from that story first you need to
understand how your emotions are
affecting you understand what emotions
you feel when you're trading and how you
impulsively act based on those emotions
if you don't have an idea of what they
are then you won't have a chance to be
successful at trading second your
emotions are all connected like a web
the first emotion I felt there was the
fear of the trade not working out and me
losing money I then got frustrated with
myself because I skipped a massive
winning trade that I knew I should have
been in and then on top of that I took a
trade that I knew I shouldn't have been
in and created a loss so now in these
situations not only are you not up money
but you're actually down money on the
day this is why one simple change can
have a drastic effect on your trading
results if I was able to jump in on that
first trade the cascading effect that
skipping it wouldn't have happened so
what you need to do is start to write
down your emotions when you're trading
and how you react to them how do they
Cascade into each other because this is
how you start to build a foundation of
your emotional web and you'll see how
everything is connected now because
you'll start to find you have a lot of
emotions that are negatively affecting
your trading results let me tell you how
you can fix that let's talk about habits
real quick common habits that you're
used to is something like going to the
gym once a day versus going to the gym
every other day this is a very tangible
habit but our emotions actually have
habits too our brain naturally gets into
habits of how it emotionally reacts to
situations just like my story about the
emotional path I go down after fearfully
skipping the first tra this is a bad
habit my brain had and I had to figure
out how to change it you have mental
habits that your brain repeats over and
over some are good habits and some are
bad habits the key is to finding ones
that are negatively affecting your
trading and change them this takes a lot
of hard work now the steps to actually
fixing this is initially you just need
to become aware of them and as you
become aware of them over time this
awareness will get stronger and stronger
in the beginning you will still notice
these habits and reactions that you have
in hindsight but slowly just like I did
you will start to notice it earlier and
earlier until you can stop your before
you act for an example when I was scared
to jump into a trade I eventually
started catching myself in real time
wanting to skip that trade opportunity I
then remind myself that it's perfectly
normal to be scared or nervous about
getting into a trade there's so much
Unknown about it but I wouldn't let my
emotions control my actions and skip the
trade like I had done in the past and so
this is how you can break the negative
habits that are affecting your trading
so I would then take the trade and not
let my emotions control my actions
that's the key here you can feel
whatever you want when you're trading
but you can also decide how you want to
react to those emotions just because you
feel angry at someone and your first
instinct is to punch them in the face it
doesn't mean you have to do that you
could decide to kiss them instead even
though you're angry at them now this is
a great start to change your training
for the better but I eventually realized
that just understanding how your
emotions affect you and the patterns
they create wasn't enough to be
consistently profitable there's still a
big key to the puzzle that you need to
be able to take your trading to the next
level so I used to have days where I
felt like I was trading flawlessly and
emotion would come up and usually that
would trigger me and it didn't seem like
a problem but I couldn't understand why
some days I would trade perfectly then
others it would be an emotional roller
coaster where I was chasing trades
impulsively jumping into them or even
Revenge trading these days would usually
wipe out all the gains I had on days
where I was trading really well and as a
fellow Trader I know this is happen to
you and here's why pretend that your
body has a battery when you're well
rested like after a restful weekend or
vacation your body battery is really
full you are more likely to have
patience to deal with frustrating things
you know going back to the example
somebody screaming at your face is
easier to deal with you know you don't
feel the need to punch them in the face
versus after a long draining day at work
your body battery is really low and it's
much easier for you to get pissed off of
that person yelling at you and
impulsively punch them in the face what
I eventually realized though was this is
the exact way your trading goes on days
where you are trading flawlessly without
impulsively reacting to your emotions
your body battery is generally very high
and you're really well rested and days
that you aren't rested and your body
battery is really low your emotions will
really easily take control of you and
you'll act impulsively the key here is
to start to become aware of that and
where it is in relation to when you're
trading and how it plays into your
trading if you think about it why not
only trade at times when you're your
body battery is high let me show you how
you can use this to become extremely
consistent when you're trading
eventually I realized that my trading
results were correlated with my stress
and how rested I was when I wasn't
stressed and well rested I would have
good trading returns but when I was
stressed and not sleeping properly I
would be more likely to make a bad
trading decision and it would end up
causing me to lose money but you have to
know when you need to take a break and
reset your body battery this can vary on
how drained you are sometimes you need
just a good night's rest to be ready to
go the next day and other times you need
a whole week's vacation to get back to
normal this is something you'll get
better at understanding over time and
it's something I'm still working on
myself I've actually noticed that I have
what seems like a boom and bus cycle
where I am really in the zone trading
and I'm being consistently profitable
and then I'll overwork myself and my
body batter will become really depleted
and I'll still continue to try and trade
and I won't reset properly I'll start to
make consistent you know trading
mistakes the key though is to be able to
reset and take a break before your body
battery becomes so drained that it
negatively affects your trading that's
the key here trading will always be
there the key is to be there when you
are ready to trade the only thing you
can really control in trading is when
you jump into a trade the outcome of the
trade what the Market's doing they're
all completely out of your control so
every time you sit down at your desk to
trade you better be at Peak Performance
levels because trading is a war and you
better be ready to fight every single
time you know you wouldn't show up to
fight tired and not able to give it to
your all right that's the great thing
when it comes to trading is you can
choose when you want to show up to fight
a really big realization I actually had
was even the most successful Traders out
there that are making millions still
have ups and downs and they're not
emotionalist robots that execute their
strategy perfectly they still have
negative emotions that they have to deal
with and ups and downs and you will have
emotions that negatively affect you but
if you are able to trade only when
you're well rested the impulses that you
have based on those emotions will be
manageable over time you will be able to
slowly stop reacting to those emotions
change the habits that are negatively
affecting your trading and switch them
into positive habits that will cause you
to be a consistently profitable Trader
here's some amazing trading advice from
six coaches that will take your trading
to the next level let's get in to number
one too many people are looking for that
easy solution and the reality is as we
know it's not that that straightforward
what we have to do and that actually
that first point there is Embrace
rejection we have to get used to we're
talking about being hardwired get used
to taking losses and yet most people
almost can't accept that even if you
said to someone I can give you a
strategy which has I don't know for arum
say a 60% uh success rate and they would
be happy while sat in this room with you
um saying yeah okay I'll be happy with
that as soon as they go through
losers that's it then they start to
hesitate and they start to second guess
and make all of those decisions which
all of a sudden makes them underperform
the strategy so yes I'm a big believer
that it takes time and um embracing
rejection I'd always say to someone look
you've got to accept taking losses don't
get so all encompassed in that one trade
that you're taking right now this one
trade you're taking right now is just
one trade in the next thousand trades
try to put it in perspective and
actually minimize the importance of the
the very next trade that you're taking
it's all those sort of little tricks
that a Trader can can take to um to help
at least it's easy for me to say I've
been there and we've been there trading
for years but at least if they make some
little notes of this sort of thing then
it might actually help them now trading
can be a difficult profession for that
can we sit in front of our computers all
day long and we feel unproductive if
we're not always in a trade or pushing
buttons you know we follow Traders on
Twitter who tweet a new idea or ticker
every 35 seconds and we say hey that guy
trades 80 to 90 tickers a day I need to
do the same thing no I think that's BS I
don't I think you should not do the same
thing I think you need to stick with
your high probability setups the setups
you know you're going to be profitable
on I'd say at least 75 80 hopefully 90%
of the time now sometimes it can be hard
to sit on your hands and and be patient
wait for those setups but why why Chase
subpar setups you know why Chase boredom
trades why put good money after
bad now how many of us here of Traders
have followed a chat room a Twitter or
friend into an idea that we knew was not
a high probability setup for our own
trading style now we all have different
trading Styles here what works for you
may not work for me personally I'm a
terrible long biased Trader if and when
I ever do go long I take profits
extremely fast knowing that a lot of
times profits can just get get away from
me pretty quick I don't have the
patience nor the conviction you know to
hold
them that's why month after month year
after year I personally get more strict
about the trades that I place I probably
Place half the amount of Trades I did
maybe just five years ago but I make way
more money why because I trade the high
probability setup setups that I know I'm
going to be profitable on 80 to 90% of
the time I like to use size with those
trades and I have very strict rules when
it comes to cutting losses fomo is an
anxiety fomo is a fear fear and anxiety
occur when we perceive
threat the problem this is a very
important concept the problem is not
that we have missed a potential trading
opportunity the problem is that we
perceive that to be a threat to us to
our success to our
future so once something becomes a
threat we go into stress
mode and literally our brains respond
with a what's known as a fight or flight
response we're priming ourselves for
Action how do we do that the blood flow
if we were in a functional magnetic
resonance imaging machine we would see
the blood flow in the brain go from the
frontal cortex to the motor areas of the
brain Prim in us for Action because
we're perceiving an emergency right now
what goes on in the brain's frontal
cortex higher level thinking higher
level thinking judging planning all the
things we're supposed to be doing when
we're trading well the blood is Flowing
away from those regions of the brain
into the action areas
so as long as we perceive threat we're
going to be shifting our blood flow to a
more impulsive action-oriented mode
rather than focusing our mind the key to
overcoming fear is taking the threat out
of the situation we're always going to
miss opportunities where have some of
the biggest opportun
been recently in financial markets
crypto yeah in crypto some big moves
guess what all of us missed every one of
those moves why aren't you
upset if you're afraid of missing out
you missed out on some big moves okay
you can only trade what you focus
on and none of us has perfect Focus so
we want to take the threat out of that
we which means we want to normalize that
to build discipline folks you're going
to have to grit your
tea and stick to the process so the
first step would be to sit down with one
of these guys sit down with put
together your training plan a simple
mechanical plan the more mechanical the
better and then my challenge to you
folks is to follow that plan without
deviation
for a batch of somewhere between 20 and
traes that's going to take quite a bit
of doing it is a right of passage no I'm
not a psychologist I've had
psychologists in my classes and they
still don't know why this happens but to
build a
habit okay any habit you've got to grit
your teeth and do it and then all of a
sudden you actually build this neural
pathway between your ears by doing it
you're going to find that sticking to
the rules for the first few trades is
difficult somewhere between five and 13
trades you build the
pathway and you'll find that the
discipline to stick to the
rules is no longer
required because that's what what you
do so my challenge to you
all is out of this get busy make a
nuisance of yourself get yourself to a
point where you've got a written plan
that sus you should not be more than one
page and then the
real
exercise is to
focus on perfect execution of that plan
for somewhere between five and 20 trads
the one thing that I can say which is
positive that everybody in this room is
eight to 13 trads away from the trader
you want to be that's all most say
trading mistakes made by beginners even
intermediates and occasionally even
Advanced people when they lose their
heads is uh to do with trade
sizing so they take a loss too big
there's nothing there's no damage done
in taking your managed loss that's part
of the game and and being wrong um the
problem is that recovery ladder when you
then emotionally negatively respond to
taking an already slightly bigger loss
so let's say you lose 15 or 20% and then
you think damn I want to get back to
where I was so I need to make 25% so
I'll trade bigger again I'm sure I'm
right this time you can't cope with the
mental um it's like a mental cognizance
um dissonance uh cognitive dissonance
that makes you need to get back to where
you once were because you're now seeing
yourself as the Lesser self as dictated
by this balance and that then
pressurizes you into trading bigger
again on what looks like a sure thing
but now you punch drunk because you must
find an opportunity quickly and it's not
a sure thing it's the first thing you
grabbed hold of um that best represents
a possible trade so you're then
bastardizing your criteria to grab hold
of something that you expect to leverage
you back into where you once were this
is a very big fatal spiral because once
again you then over trade because you've
got to make back more um to get back up
and that's the recovery ladder concept
and boom that's that is probably the
single most destructive uh that sees
someone have a £10,000 account reduced
to you know a few hundred or ,000 and
then virtually giving up realizing that
they've they' they've blown it learning
to trade without fear hesitation or
internal conflict is a function of
believing that you don't have to know
what's going to happen next on a trade
bytrade basis to win or make consistent
money this is this is a hard of it right
here everyone okay this is the heart of
it but eventually what you're going to
do is get to the point where you believe
that you do not have to know what is
going to happen next on a trade bytrade
basis this trade and this particular
trade and this particular trade you
don't have to enter these trades
thinking that you know what's going to
happen next to win to make consistent
money and that when you stop believing
that you will start making consistent
money
because it's the it's your expectations
about this trade winning that's that's
going to mess you up go ahead what
you're really saying is you have to have
a belief in your plan or your
methodology and you're looking for a
probabilistic result saying over a
period of time I will execute 60 70 80%
of my traits the one I'm going into now
could be a good one could be a bad one I
don't care that's right exactly right
perfect thank you thinking assuming or
believing you know what will happen next
creates an unrealistic expectation in a
in a specific outcome what's wrong with
an unrealistic expectation well think
about let's say expectations in
relationship to the the characteristics
of humanity you could this cuts across
all everybody and cuts across all
cultural all cultural lines or barriers
everyone well first of all we get get to
that point what is an expectation an
expectation is a mental representation
in other words a belief in a
assumption or an opinion or whatever
thinking assuming or believing a mental
representation of what the next moment
meaning next moment next 5 seconds or
the next in 10 seconds or the next hour
or whatever is either going to end the
environment in other words we have a
mental representation and we have an
external environment that expresses
itself okay so my mental representation
meaning my expectation if the if the
environment shows up in a way that is
consistent with what I
believe then what What will what will my
state of mind be this is a universal
characteristic of humanity this isn't
any different with anybody
anywhere how will I feel what will be my
state of
mind what will be my experience I'll be
in a state of
satisfaction a state of
well-being I could be joyous I could
even end up in in a state of
euphoria the degree to which the
environment does not express itself in a
way that's consistent what I the way in
consistent with the way I think it's
either going to look like sound like
taste like smell like or feel like okay
I will be in a state of
dissatisfaction a state of
betrayal disgust
anger fear Terror your ability to create
create consistent results as a Trader is
all about what you expect when you
change your expectations to be
consistent with the way the environment
the market environment exists the fear
will go
away when you change your expectations
in a way that's consistent with the way
the actual Market environment exists
your fear will go away and you'll be
able to do exactly what you need to do
when you need to do
it with without conflict without
hesitation and be able to close that
profit gap between what your methodology
will give you and what you end up with
in your bottom line I've had a trading
coach for the last 3 years and it's been
the most Roi positive thing that I've
done in my trading and my life and so in
this video I want to walk you through
the nine most impactful lessons that
I've learned from him over the years now
a bit of backstory on Evan he has 25
plus years managing and trading money
and he has ranom trading floors with
over 100 plus Traders and now he coaches
some of the top hedge funds in the world
and professional athletes and still runs
a small fund of his own and somehow I
have been lucky enough to land him as a
mentor so let me pass on to you what he
has taught me over the years on what it
takes to be a consistently profitable
Trader the prep you do before you even
sit down to trade is one of the most
important things you can do in trading
but what are you doing before you go to
bed to make sure you're ready for the
next trading day I always used to think
that your morning routine and pre-t
trading routine was the most important
prep that you could do but what was
really a game changer for me was when
Evan brought up the importance of a
nighttime routine morning routines help
you get the day started but if you don't
even sleep well the night before then it
won't matter what you do the next day
you will still be tired and exhausted
the night time for me that we have
created starts at 8:00 p.m. every day I
leave my phone in my office then I take
a hot shower to relax my body and start
the production of melatonin which is a
sleep hormone then I stretch to loosen
my body up before getting in bed then I
read before falling asleep once I
started doing this my sleep got
extremely consistent and I naturally
Wake Up Now around 6:00 a.m. well rested
every day when I first started with Evan
I was trading as long as I could every
day because I wanted to catch every
trade that the day had to offer if I
wasn't watching the market then I was
theoretically missing out on money Evan
explained that after around 1100 a.m. US
market time most day Traders actually
lose money in the long run this of
course depends on when you trade and how
you trade but the biggest factor in this
statistic was that after 11:00 a.m. is
generally when most day Traders have
been trading since the market open which
is around 9:30 he explained that the
biggest reason behind this is because
it's almost impossible to be at the
level of focus trading requires for more
than a couple of hours at a time so
after about 1 and 1/2 to 2 hours you
start to lose that mental focus that it
takes to make good trading decisions and
you start making worse trading decisions
so even though trading longer you get
more opportunities to trade you are less
likely to make the right decision and
more likely to make a mistake losing you
money so spend less time trading you do
not need to sit in front of the computer
all day long it will make you more
profitable every time an athlete shows
up to a competition or a game they are
doing everything they can to make sure
they are as ready as possible and on top
of their game the biggest mental shift
Evan said that was important for Traders
to become consistently profitable was to
treat trading like an athlete show up
every day at your Peak Performance this
is where your whole life and day-to-day
activities come into play like staying
physically fit so you're mentally
setting up routines before you trade so
you're ready to go or creating that
nighttime routine so you're well rested
and focused the next day just because
it's you trading does not mean there
aren't other athletes on the other side
of the computer looking to take your
money now over the 3 years I've been
with Evan we are constantly in a process
of simplifying and narrowing down my
focus as much as possible I was always
stuck in the idea that to make more
money in trading I needed to make more
trades and over time I've realized it's
the complete opposite I used to trade
multiple strategies and now I only focus
on looking for reversal trades in the
market I used to trade many hours in the
day and now I only trade one to 1 and 1
half hours a day and with my trading I'm
always trying to take less trades less
often with the idea that I'm only
getting in the best trades possible that
are more likely to make you consistently
profitable Evan constantly enforces the
idea that less is more this idea alone
started to turn me into a consistently
profitable Trader now the trades you
take are all that matter when it comes
to trading the ones you miss out or skip
don't affect your account balance in the
end only the ones you end up getting
into to get better at this Evan says
it's important to work on something he
likes to call being aggressively patient
intentionally going into every trading
day waiting for the market to fit your
strategy is the key I spent so much time
in the beginning focusing on trying to
fit what the Market was doing but the
most profitable Traders are the ones
that are patiently waiting for the
market to come to them and fit their
strategy they trade when they are ready
to trade they don't chase trades they
are worried they might miss out on even
if it means you don't trade for a few
days that's how you can consistently
make money when you execute trades Evan
says he's only taken six trades this
whole year and it's been his best year
yet that is how patient you can end up
being I used to be scared to jump in a
trade and my habit was to skip the trade
out of fear there's a saying that Under
Pressure you don't rise to the occasion
you actually sink to your level of
trading trading is the exact same way we
all have habits that can affect our
trading negatively and slowly over time
with training you can actually change
those habits but this takes time to
build and change that muscle memory of
that habit that you have over time in
coaching I was able to accept that the
nervousness to trade is okay thus I
changed my habit and eventually even
when that pressure comes up again of
fear of jumping into a trade I Fall to
my training and the training tells me to
execute the trade no matter how I feel
every trade that we take is
mathematically separate from the last
statistically you can go on massive loss
streaks and still be in the normal
statistics of trading the only problem
is as humans we have emotions and we
can't easily separate trades I don't
know about you but when I take a loss it
frustrates me and affects me emotionally
I'd like to say it doesn't affect the
rest of my focus of trading that day but
it does so even though each trade
outcome isn't connected our emotions
connect each trade Evan constantly
stresses the importance of being aware
of your feelings during trading the
biggest reason Traders lose money is
they let their emotions take control of
them so you want to be aware of where
you are mentally when you're trading so
you can step away when you aren't able
to handle your emotions and stop them
from negatively affecting your trading
even Evan as someone who has been
trading most of his life says those
emotions will always be there even he
has them every day the best Traders out
there still deal with their emotions
every day but they have learned to
become extremely self-aware and know
that when they need to step away from
Trading the mindset Evans says every
Trader should try and work towards is
being comfortable with the UN certainty
of trading but certain about your
abilities and behavior to act
accordingly you will always have fear
doubt or nervousness when it comes to
trading even now that I've been
consistently profitable for a while I
always have doubts that maybe I don't
know what I'm doing you never know what
the Market's going to do next so instead
Emin says it's important to focus on
your mental abilities when reacting to
situations that come up in the market
because over time it won't matter as
much what the market is doing you will
make the right decision
no matter the level of uncertainty or
outcome that's all trading is it's a
test of your ability to make the correct
decision with uncertain or not all the
information over and over Evan likes to
say trading is the hardest game in the
world and that in a couple of hours of
trading you make more decisions than
most jobs do in a full 8 hour day I
always thought when the market is open
you should be trading because you're
missing out on potential money but it's
actually been the opposite the less Le I
trade the better my results you don't
need to trade every day take a day off
to recharge because compared to a normal
job making a mistake in trading loses
you money it's not about just showing up
and doing the work like a lot of 9 to-5
jobs it's about showing up to make as
good of decisions as you can
consistently it doesn't matter if you
can make profitable trades most of the
time if you wipe out all your gains with
one bad day a week or every month if you
want to start making $500 or more a day
trading there are two negative trading
Loops that you have to be aware of and
break out of if you don't you will be
stuck struggling at trading for years I
see it constantly myself included was
stuck in these two loops and there are
the whole reason you are probably right
now jumping from strategy to strategy
trying to be consistently profitable and
so I want to walk you through what these
two Loops are and how you can break out
of them to eventually becoming
consistently profitable the whole
journey of becoming a consistent Trader
is a struggle in the beginning where you
are generally just consistently losing
or just not making any money and once
you actually break out of these Loops
your Equity curve and profitability will
go from flatlining to losing to
consistently profitable this is the
whole goal that all of us as Traders
want and so let me walk you through what
these are and how you can break out of
them and so I look at trading is there
are three stages of becoming profitable
and the first stage is that you are
stuck in what is called a learning Loop
and so how this works as you come into
trading you know you first start you
find a strategy you like and you start
testing it out and so you do this for a
couple weeks couple months you know you
have some success but eventually you
start to become not consistently
profitable with it and so you stop
getting good results or you're just not
getting the results you want and so then
of course like logically with anything
else in life you look to go back and
learn more cuz generally with anything
in life is if you learn more you become
better at it so you either look to find
a new strategy or you look to add either
different Candlestick patterns or other
indicators to the strategy and so then
again you start to test that out but lo
and behold you aren't getting the
results you want and so you go back to
the drawing board of either scrapping
everything trying to find a new strategy
or adding new things to it and so you
get stuck in this cycle I was stuck in
this cycle for years jumping from
strategy to strategy because I didn't
find something that worked for me but I
also didn't stop myself from being stuck
in this cycle and so we're going to talk
about how you can break out of this but
first I want to talk about the second
Loop that you can get stuck in because
once you break out of this you're going
to go right into another trap that I
call the self Savatage Loop once you
learn more about trading you'll start to
realize that there are a lot of emotions
in it especially when you start trading
real money things can get very intense
you can get emotional you can start
foming into the trades getting nervous
frustrated impulsivity comes in your
trading and so there is this whole web
of emotions that negatively impact your
trading and so all of these different
feelings greed Euphoria desperation they
make it so you are self sabotaging your
trading and so let me illustrate what
this can look like and what my
self-sabotage Loop look like because you
will start to see how this Cycle Works
and how it self-sabotaged me and will
give you insight to what yours might
look like and so for me my biggest issue
with trading was I had the fear of being
wrong I was scared of a trade losing
losing money during that trade and so
any time that I would see a potential
opportunity come whatever strategy I was
trading I would start to get nervous
when the time came to enter and so I
that fear would come in and take control
of me and so then I would skip the trade
and of course generally because I'm
following a strategy that works most of
the time that would work out that trade
would have worked out and I would have
been able to make a profitable trade and
so instead because I skipped out on that
trade I became frustrated because I
missed out on the money I could have
made from that trade which was
frustrating and so that frustration
would stay with me as I'm still watching
the charts and what it would do is I
would be sitting there waiting for
another trade opportunity to come and
something would kind of start to set up
but let's say if I have a checklist you
know of five things I'm looking for to
jump into a trade three out of five of
them would show up and I would say you
know what this is good enough I'm going
to jump in because I don't want to miss
out on this trade because I did that
just for the last one and it worked out
and so I fomed into a trade now because
I was frustrated and it allowed my
emotions to can take control of me and
so from there generally because I'm
jumping in on a bad trade now based on
fomo is it would turn into a loss and I
would become even more frustrated and
sometimes this would turn into something
even worse tunnel vision Panic you know
I would start to Revenge trade even and
I would take more losses but eventually
I would get to a point where I say okay
I have to take a break I got to be done
with trading for the day I need to
either take tomorrow off or you know
somehow reset and come back to the
drawing board right and of course I
would reset but those emotions and
underlying reasons of why I you know had
the fear of being wrong would restart
and this cycle would just continue and
so that would be how I would be stuck in
I still broke out of the learning Loop
but now I'm stuck in another loop of
just self-sabotaging myself over and
over and this is something I constantly
see other people struggling with they'll
have a strategy but they'll have all
these emotions that are just negatively
impacting their trading and if we don't
learn how to deal with these and stop
them from controlling our actions we're
never going to get to the end goal of
becoming consistently profitable and so
I want to walk you through how we can
combat these three stages how we can go
from being stuck in the learning Loop to
being in the self-sabotage Loop and
breaking out of both of those to become
consistently profitable and I'm
confident that I know what I have will
help you because I've heard it from
other people that they were jumping from
strategy to strategy until they learned
some of the stuff I'm about to teach you
and it helped them break out of those
loops and become consistently profitable
and so let's first work on how we can
break out of the learning Loop because
that's generally the one that I think
stops the most people and so the first
thing with doing that is you have to
find a strategy that works for you and
so my strategy is super simple over time
I realized that you know through all the
strategies I was trying out all I could
really be confident in that hey I know
how how to find clear support or
resistance zones and I can see that the
market can clearly bounce off those
levels and so I created a strategy based
on that all this does is it's a simple
process of I wait for the market to come
down to the one of these levels and then
I look for on a smaller time frame chart
generally I trade on a one minute chart
and then I essentially follow my step
pattern and then step two is waiting for
you know kind of the current Trend to
come down and then step three three is I
look for kind of a reversal pattern and
then I jump in betting that the market
is going to go higher and I usually go
for you know a three times risk reward
ratio so if I'm risking something like
$150 here I'll eventually manage to
trade and you know here I made about
$600 on a trade so it was about a 4X
trading so that was a really nice profit
and so this isn't something I'm going to
go into a ton of detail here because I
have a ton of YouTube videos explaining
this but the whole idea is that you need
to narrow down your focus and so for me
that's what looking solely at reversal
patterns did is instead of trying to you
know catch every swing in the market of
okay I'm going to catch a reversal here
I'm going to look for a continuation
trade up here instead I'm just looking
for one specific thing every day and
that's all I do what I've realized as
well is because all I do is I really
just look at the Candlestick patterns I
use just a couple of trend lines you
know support and resistance zones that
it simplifies things really well and it
allows you to actually trade this on
really any Market or time frame because
these Candlestick patterns are just
reflection of the price and what the
market is doing and so this can apply to
any market and one thing that narrowed
this down even more for me and I've
always found that to get out of that
learning Loop the better thing to do is
take things away what can you do that
will take away things that are
negatively impacting your trading if
trading you know three different
patterns is negatively impacting your
trading take out one or two that you
don't feel like you're consistently as
profitable with and so another thing
that really helped me narrow things down
over time was looking at kind of 30
minute reversals is what I realized is
just consistently looking at the market
is looking at the NASDAQ futures and S&P
500 futures is 30 minutes after the open
if on these charts The Market opens at
6:30 which is West Coast time it's 30
minutes around 7:00 is that's when the
markets reverse a lot and so that's how
I narrowed down my focus even more and
stuck with a really solid strategy so I
you know don't don't go back in that
learning Loop you got to be aware these
Loops once you break out of it you can
go right back into it if you're not
careful and so that's something I'm
always working towards is just getting
better and and more narrow focuses every
chart of these These are from one
specific month and you can see at 7:00
there's a really nice The Market opens
kind of moves down makes a really nice
double bottom and then reverses and so
this is something that I find that is
super repeatable and that this is how
you want to approach trading is find
something that you are confident in and
that you can consistently do day in in
and day out because if you spend your
time trying to just jump around and you
know react to the what the market is
doing instead of going in and having a
plan you're not going to become
consistently profitable and so that's
something that I have found to be really
beneficial and another really cool tool
that I actually made I call the news
Navigator is when you're trading Futures
and the S SMP 500 is that well there's a
lot of news that comes out and so just
to quickly show you is here's a news
release platform I use it's just called
Forex Factory and it just shows every
day okay there is news releases that are
either red and you got to be really
aware of or there's just yellow ones
that aren't a big deal or some orange
ones and what I realized is this doesn't
actually do a good job of saying what is
important or not and so what I did is I
just looked at you know every release
and took data over time of saying okay
what's the release what's the potential
movement and so is there actually
potential movement and so can I trade
through the release and so there's not
many that happen 15 minutes after the
Market opens but there's a ton that
happen an hour before the Market opens
and 30 minutes after the Market opens
and so this 30 minute one that happens
after the market open these ones are
really important to pay attention to
because there's some that you got to be
aware of that cause massive movement and
some that are just no movement at all
and you can trade through and so that is
something that I found really really
helpful with just narrowing my focus
down even more and so that's really how
you have to break out of that learning
Loop is find something that you like and
stick to it it doesn't have to be my
strategy we all have different trading
personalities and what you know makes
sense for us and what we feel
comfortable with I feel comfortable with
taking reversal trades because that's
what I just mentally makes sense I can
see that okay when the market comes down
for me I see that okay there's a good
risk reward here and that makes a lot of
sense for me versus some people they're
just better at continuation trades but
for me mentally that just doesn't work
and so the second thing is once you
break out of that you're going to be put
right into the self- sabotage Loop and
so there's four steps to breaking out of
this Loop and so the important ones are
is building awareness of what your
emotions are that negatively impactor
trading you know my big ones were you
know the fear of being wrong and so
starting to be become aware of just what
those are the frustration of missing
profits maybe yours is fomo maybe yours
is greed or desperation to you know make
a lot of money quickly and so you have
to then once you become aware of what
those emotions are you got to understand
how you react impulsively to those
actions and so for me you know my fear
of being wrong would lead me to skip a
tradeit and that I don't necessarily
want to logically skip a trade I want to
logically be following my plan but as
humans we follow our emotions a lot
we're emotional beings they take control
over us and impulsively cause us to do
things and so a lot of the time is we
are reactionary based on our emotions
and what we need to learn to do is we
need to overcome our impulsivity to
react to those emotions and so instead
we want to react how we want and so
instead what a really good way to
illustrate this is I still when a trade
comes up I still have that innate fear
of being wrong and so I get nervous and
instead of skipping a trade out of that
fear I have created a new pattern and a
way I react instead of reacting based on
my emotions and my fear I say no I want
to jump into this trade and so when I
would jump into that trade it would
break that self-sabotage Loop and it
would start this new Loop of I jump in a
trade and I would start to build
confidence in my ability to trade and so
then it would come up to the next trade
and I would still have that same emotion
of being fearing fear of being wrong but
instead I've now started to learn to
control those actions and I consistently
react accordingly and how I want to and
so that's the biggest thing to help
break yourself out of that Loop is
instead of letting your emotions control
you you feel your emotions except that
you feel that way it's okay to be scared
that you're going to be wrong we're not
robots it's a part of who we are and in
instead you just say okay I feel that
way but I'm still going to do what I
want to do and so this is the basic
framework of breaking out of that
learning Loop breaking out of the
self-sabotage Loop and becoming
consistently profitable now just because
you know this doesn't mean it's not
going to be easy it's still going to be
really hard and so what I've done to
help accelerate this for you is I've
created a 90day confident Trader program
that is designed to help you break out
of both of these loops and become
consistently profitable as fast as
possible and I'm confident that this
will help you drastically accelerate and
improve your trading because I've seen
it do that for people already people
that have were struggling for so long
they were losing and just consistently
you know in that part of the learning
curve where they're just not making
consistent money and then they join the
program and they start to see that
change in their Equity curve where
they're consistently profitable month
after month and it's just awesome to see
where these people are saying you know
they've been struggling and not
consistent for 3 and 1/2 years and
they're way more consistent than ever
you know they feel like they finally
found their strategy if they're using my
reversal strategy but it's also helping
them just break those cycles that you're
just stuck in as a Trader and there have
been people that have had big 50%
account returns after a year this person
down here almost has 100% return and so
what I want this to illust
is that it's helped a lot of other
people break out of these learning loops
I can never you know guarantee that you
are going to make
$96,000 in 2 months but I can guarantee
that this is going to drastically
accelerate your learning curve and your
process getting through these loops and
so let me illustrate to you how this
program is laid out and how it's going
to help you break out of the learning
Loop and then the self-sabotage Loop and
so first is right away when you jump in
is you are going to get ACC access to my
whole trading strategy and everything I
have and know about what makes a
profitable strategy and how to become
consistently with it and manage and grow
an account over time and keeping you out
of being stuck in that cycle and so the
first thing that it's going to address
is it's just going to jump start your
trading Journey it's going to help you
build your foundation of how to
understand everything that I'm talking
about going forwards but then it's going
to walk you through how to consistently
ly look for reversals because again
that's what my strategy focuses on it's
going to give you a deep dive into how I
identify those patterns the early shifts
that the market has and teach you
Advanced market movement that will help
you realize when these signals are going
to happen and so this dives into way
more depth than what my YouTube videos
do those really give a good overview of
my entry checklist and how I trade but
this gives you a super deep dive into
everything about that and then as well
it'll start to go into how to
consistently manage trades it'll go into
my road map of those 30 minute after the
market open reversals it'll give you
that news release navigator that we
talked about and it will just go through
I have hours and months of trade
examples in there and the biggest thing
about this is probably it helps you know
when to avoid entering trades even when
the signal shows up because what I see a
lot of people doing is they will follow
my five-step checklist but there's times
when you actually shouldn't be entering
in the trade and there's certain signals
that show that and then the last really
crucial thing is learning how to grow
your account and treat trading like a
business I have a three-step sizing
growth plan in there that will really
help you know how to scale properly and
go at this the right way the biggest
thing about trading and breaking that
learning Loop is you need to become
process focused and focus on
consistently executing the same strategy
because otherwise you're just going to
be stuck in this learning Loop over and
over and so all this will help you break
out of that learning Loop and then we go
on to the second part of the program
which is really where the 90 days comes
in I have a 9we framework that is going
to now start focusing on that self-
sabotage Loop and instead of you getting
stuck in that it's going to help you
break out of that and work towards
becoming consistently profitable with
your strategy what this is going to do
is it's going to be giving you weekly
actionable steps and systems that you
can use to start becoming aware of how
things are negatively affecting you it's
going to help you build your emotional
Matrix and figure out what's actually
affecting you the level that it's
affecting you and how you can actually
change how these negatively affect you
and then as well it's going to start to
bring in some other concept of your
mental capital in your body battery and
how do you can deal with LW streaks and
change those around there are a ton of
destructive emotions that affect your
trading and you need to learn how to
control them and so what this is going
to do is there are Frameworks in there
that I call the stimulus Gap response
framework that is going to stop you from
becoming impulsive and you want it'll
help you react how you want I have
another really really cool system in
there that I call the emotional spectrum
that is going to help you stay calm amid
all the chaos and help you know okay
what emotions am I okay to trade during
and when I feel certain emotions what do
I do and how do I stay away from
starting to Revenge trade and get out of
control and then the last whole phase of
this is is how you start to work to
becoming consistently profitable how you
start narrowing things down stopping the
Lost streaks and the boom and bus cycles
that really start to happen when you
start to get close to becoming
profitable and then as well what it'll
start do is it'll start to ingrain these
things into muscle memory so instead of
having that self-sabotage Loop be you
know a negative pattern you're going to
break out of that and you're going to
start to make positive patterns and
Loops that you are stuck in that are
beneficial to your trading and so
essentially successful trading will
start to become like muscle memory for
you that's what's so powerful about this
is you are think of everything like
muscle memory all our how we react to
things and how this self-sabotage Loop
works is it's just muscle memory your
body is used to saying okay I'm nervous
I'm scared I'm going to stay away from
and get away from what is making me
nervous and scared and not do whatever
that thing is and instead we re
reprogram our minds and create different
Pathways and muscle memory to create
positive emotional Loops that positively
affect our trading and so all of this
you can find in my self-paced on demand
90 confident Trader program and you can
get that in the link below and so really
what you get access with this is
everything that I have built out that is
going to help you break out of that
learning Loop and then into the self-
sabotage Loop and break out of that and
accelerate your trading to becoming
consistently profitable and so there are
a there's hours and hours on my strategy
and how to consistently execute that
because you know that's one of the most
important things but then you also have
that N9 weeks of your trading mindset
focused work you're going to get
lifetime access to all this you're going
to get a ton of tools guides routines
and as well as Frameworks to help build
your trading career you're going to get
that news release navigator that I
talked about earlier and as well there's
a couple of things I've added in as
exclusive bonuses I've added in lifetime
community access to my exclusive trading
chat room and generally this is a
monthly subscription and so it's going
to save you a ton of money for that but
as well this is really helpful and once
you've gone through this whole program
and used all these tools gone through
those 90day days you're still going to
want continued help and education and
what this community does is it's an
extremely active community that helps
each other and not just for me but
everyone else there is focused on the
same thing and they're going to know all
these materials that you're working on
too and so it's going to help you bounce
ideas off of each other and as well off
of me and get help anytime you need
another thing that I added is I have
learned a ton about the mental side of
trading for from my actual trading coach
he focuses mainly on the mental side of
trading with me and what we did is we
sat down for an hour and a half session
and talked about what it will take for
someone starting with this strategy he
knows his strategy very well cuz I've
worked with him for coming up on 4 years
now is how we can tailor all of this and
best make it work for you someone coming
from a beginner or you know stuck in
those loops and how they can start to
break them going forward and so this is
an hour and a half session that is
highly focused on that and I think you
will find it insanely beneficial to have
someone else's perspective as well on
all this and then the last thing is
because I'm so confident in this program
drastically improving and changing your
trading just from how much effort I've
put into it but also just reviews from
other people is that I have 100%
guarantee to give you a refund no
questions asked in the first 30 days if
you for any reason it doesn't matter
want a refund just email me and I will
happily give it to you the idea is this
is you know I understand there's a lot
of shady stuff out there online and I
just want to make this kind of a
risk-free investment for you to help
accelerate your journey and trading by
saving you a lot of time but also saving
you a lot of money I lost a lot of money
making a ton of mistakes and trying to
break out of these Loops myself and so
what this is going to do is it's going
to help you do that for less money and
less time and so I highly recommend
checking out the link below it'll go
into way more in depth and show you kind
of everything that's in the platform
more than I've talked to here and of
course you don't have to get the program
we talked about ways for you to break
out of the learning Loop and the
self-sabotage Loop already and so feel
free to keep going about it on your own
if you want and if that works for you if
not though I'll see you inside